who's fat checking the fat tracker what
do we know is correct information what
isn't covert is this great case study
that illuminates how something that is
considered a fat within a couple of
years isn't there's a theory of facts
called the half-life of fats that in any
discipline what you think of as a fat
will change in its status so the Wuhan
lab leak labeled absolutely firmly by
fat Checkers media and politicians and
public health scientists as a conspiracy
theory now thought to be plausible so we
have to be really careful about being so
sure that information should be labeled
as misinformation or disinformation when
Facebook label posts that way they know
that they reduce engagement by about 85
percent ah okay so if you were to share
an article about climate change that
Facebook's climate change Resource
Center whatever it's called considers to
be misinformation it might not take it
down it might just label it as
misinformation and then you'll get a lot
less clicks